I can't think of an entrepreneur side
chef Bezos who's a freak of nature whose
first business becomes the most valuable
business in the world most people have a
graveyard of failures behind them the
idea is you start not with the incentive
saying this is going to be the one thing
for the rest of my life which is the
fallacy that employees have when in
relatives I just have to do a thing that
I'm good enough at that I can learn the
game and the thing is once you start
taking steps The Next Step becomes
illuminated you trying to think a
hundred steps into the future when you
have no context is irrelevant because
chaos is going to break your plan
anyways and so do what you know I like
service businesses to start because they
are in my opinion the lowest risk to
start it's just your time